à dix mois et dit oui j'aime pas trop
parler des chaussettes noires je sais
c'est une époque je dirais sombre de ta
vie puisque non non pas du tout ça fait
partie de l'histoire du rock maintenant
les chaussettes noires jean début un peu
lent a bien peur alors dit moi ça a
commencé comment tu étais donc
travailler dans une société d'assurances
et nous l'enclos paul oncle paul
généralement enclos paul ses deux neveux
vilaine fille pendant la pièce bon non
c'est simple je pense être donc
des buts 72 50 ash c'est très bien mon
bref ça marche immédiatement donc on
peut pas parler de de travail de vache
enragée de ceci de cela on a fait un
premier disque ça marche tout de suite
car il y avait un copain à toi qui
s'appelait chicheportiche c'est ça oui
jean pierre rives et aldo voile et tony
williams faisait monter un groupe qui
s'appelait les five rocks moi je veux
transformer et alors si c'est l'histoire
qui est incroyable c'est que la première
fois que j'ai entendu le disque à la
radio vous êtes aperçu qu'en fait
barclays avec qui vous aviez signé non
votre dos il est ça un deal avec les
chaussettes ce thème ouais pour appeler
ça les chaussettes noires si vous à
flipper complètement non l'important
était de faire un disque après ouais je
te ferai pas valu que peu plus à feurs
il doit utiliser le chanteur parce
qu'ils aient pas d'ampli apporter c'est
ça alors ouais tu laissais des autres
chariots il n'y avait pas de roudouallec
porté leurs matelas rempli et enchanteur
avec maman le peuvent c'était l'époque
de la bande fameuse bande de la trinité
et du tronc il y avait
longue crise ici on glande you le père
david ensuite donc il y avait johnny
hallyday est un baston avec johnny pour
une histoire de disques de jean vincent
c'est vrai ça vous allez tirer sur un
ton c'est un terme très fort ouais non
il ya eu tu te rends compte que nous
entraîne non il dit bon on peut pas
regagner bon j'étais furieux j'avais
amené des dix comme des mômes coin
jardin des délices qui lui allait
chauffer ce que j'aurais certainement
sur place et est bon et je c'est
malheureux parce que ces disques la
retrouvons n'ai trouvé nulle part et
donc je vais entre cadieux from here on
demande en papier nous sinon plus et en
devenu très content c'est qu'il plupart
étaient quand même le plus fort s'ils
avaient eu la guerre qu'est-ce que
regagner le port si c'est pas je pense
parce que je t'aime papa garçons c'est
ce genre de coqs merlet drôle vous êtes
amis puis toujours finalement ques et
stressé très très étonnant et m'a jamais
rendu venus alors il ya eu le groupe
s'est séparé en 63 procès enfin mme
asselin galère et aujourd'hui les
chaussées de l'enset rapporte de
l'argent quand même toujours salué un
jugement lorsque tu pars en paca -
agathois et alors ce que tu aimes passé
les reprises des chaussettes ça c'est un
truc qui te sais je m'y attendais non ce
qui m'énerve c'est con mais ça tout les
uns ils ont à toutes les sauces
que c'est pas passé tous vont cependant
les vagabonds par exemple tu voyais
c'était au deuxième degré toi à moi j'ai
toujours cru que ce boulet je vais pas
gagner cependant mais durent se voulait
clin d'oeil j'espère que ça l'est
toujours du hc pourra dire alors après
bon t'es fait la carrière solo énorme
qu'on connaît terry cole un petit
passage à vide au début des 70 et a fait
une émission de radio sur france inter
qu'il savait comment en maître pendant
que ça se passait mal
beaucoup d'humour et l'ours a fait une
tournée en roumanie pays en dollars
c'est à dire moment ça ne s'est jamais
flip état nounou
pourquoi parce que tu t'en fous parce
que tu as toujours su que ça finirait
par marcher bien non parce que j'ai
toujours pris je veux dire les choses
comme elles viennent ces seniors
on doit pas aller vers le public on doit
faire les choses qu'on sent qu'on aime
là le public s'y retrouve mais quelqu'un
qui vient vers lui c'est je suis désolé
d'être vus hier mais je veux dire c'est
que c'est ce à quoi
non on n'a pas à le faire mais les gens
t'aiment pas ce que tu as un vrai bas je
suis ravie je suis d'abord je suis ravi
d'être ici
oui moi alors maman sur abu squales ont
été ravis que je te dis ça maintenant tu
vas être moins ravi parce que ben parce
qu'on veut faire du comté estime énorme
star ah oui dont je vais me faire du
fond tu n'as pas défense et on a dit aux
gens pour voir si vous étiez quand les
jambes heures les gens importants heures
on leur demande toujours dans la rue
comme les autres enfants voilà donc on a
fait comme s'il était mort
c'est sympa on a demandé aux gens dans
la rue ce qu'ils on penserait pas ce
qu'ils en pensent tu vas voir
non